we also want concealer and very
practical application of the chicory
large numbers and regulations associated
with the applique suggestion do is
polling
so a kind of a referendum that going
to take place or close enough to today
of the referent do so that water board
make up your mind and resurrection  pi or
the population
that for present the butter so that
throws there or also yes but on and on and stupid enough
jet taking place and you want to find
out to predict by estimate
what be actually what your goal is that
you go ahead and you select ted'  around
and number of people out of the population
and for something person you the court de
ranger' whether the intent to vote yes
or whether the intend to vote now
quiz said that the people are randomly
selected
in terms of timing is that we choose the juni
formula of  the population and since 1000
pills rowing boat yes this means that lies
ran away baby warm white promobility p&r
for that xpect the wind I need is boring
is equal to be in a dish and how to
dat wie select those people
independently
nou note that easy select people
independently so always shines
dat de first-person pullbuoy so she is
the second person pot
something that we do not really want to
happen gabber is hoe je your sins de
population is very large or  just idealize
the situation a bit cheating the
population is in feel it when this is
never going to happen and be well wet
beer group likes I do exactly
hulu carries out that we god of the
people that rowboat your account gold mine
icts the white at and and  whiskey 6
the fraktion or correct is in the sample that
we like at the end
and who is the criteria charge with for
the canan fraction pi the fraxel or jesse
is in that about roll
paper there is well programmer bos charged you
to find out the exact  where you or be
quick videoresponse be well there is no
way to cut jpx acli to the base or a
finite and all around pot
therefore the risk en to be some and
stir in dar es the mission of bi
temperature b  os comes back en 6 ok ben
try to gimme en estimate of be greetings
berry archer the protein like you to come
up with en nesting with good is correct
how the in one percenter point can you
this for may your answer my baby
ok let me try  polling ten thousand
people and see if i can guarantee for
you
that is beautiful after you think about
the situation little more you realize
that there is no way of guarantee sets
molar certainty evil iviewer unlucky
en de people dat je polig app en to be
not representative of the junk on your
list show you come back to your bos
en usa and can not guarantee with
certainty that die er is gran turismo de
met pep secundair en die for you
dat die er dat age at is smal we drive
probability or alternatively  and grew
to guarantee for you dat de try die
dat we get and error dat is bigger than
that is very small as soon as smileys going
to be
let's try to the right amount of this
probability of in a larger than one
percenter poi  nt using the populations
that we carried out when we arrived the
week walk of large numbers week zero that
is probability large there is tires the
ball came with quality quantity
sigma square is the variance
of animal and the roads blood that where
sapling and since this  is bernoulli these
cars is piet times oneliners pi
and we are the white with and
the good name resistant de for time web
sloane square
epsilon is dead meines tools of
jungsheft' en toe de mind for
okay but now what is this content die
visconti di  pension pi and we also
do what pi is slippery
digital is expression and plot it and
they function of be
god job toes is the lead or die stipe
and the maximum gepkens green peas i gotta
live and good kees we get the vario of
one for
that is the variants of the bernoulli is
it had to war force and therefore how
to throw on teen with band here for the die nomine terms of the sea peak of the equal to war tell your boss die
quite simple ten thousand people
l  and try die of and never more
than the one percenter point the screen
to be less than 20 5% the bike point
here both my tri-ply and c
well i try your flyer of twenty five
percent is when i this is and acceptable
i would like  you to have probably the of
en red dot slash dan 5%
zo suppo's needles to want to change
this and make it
oil en 5% er 5% or less
gift you going to proceed because you go
des quantités gerardi supper bound to
know to be  less than or equal to one for
the 5 dit at and the times ypsilon square
tutsis in her mind and then the mind
for we would like this quantity to be
less than or equal to 5 percent good she
is five over intervenes power and
after you  in the qualité you find
release equivalent to taking and larger
than or equal to
tenten so x en dan de 50 get it
good for you wash
the nominate of twent en with number is
equal to 50,000
would prefer point you can  go back to
your boat and tell them that one way of
guarant  ee that the profiles dualies
there is less than or equal to 5%
first take and equal to 50 thousend zo
50,000
will rise to achieve the designs specs
need is that the design cuneiform
parameters
one is the accuracy that you live and
theater is the confit  dance with which
the aggression is going to be a team
well 50,000 is a pretty large number of
pleasure is the risotto or pulse the know that
again recent team us peppers the user
italy that the senate you quarrel or
pleasure miners
3 percent i suppose not one  percenter
point
that money vinckx and little it means
you can do them together a little smaller
sample size and vendors another effect
ar calculations here was based on this
in the quality gothic czech
find quality but the czech
went quality is no title at the
terms  from that's how use more accurate
testament about probability will find
but actually market smaller of use of and
the will be not for purposes